y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en
france24 hoy vamos a hablar sobre la
situación del cob y 19 en varias
regiones del mundo donde la vacunación
las re aperturas pero también el repunte
de los contagios son los principales
protagonistas y para analizar el tema
nos acompaña el doctor oscar franco
epidemiólogo director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
universidad de berna académico de
harvard y de la universidad de erasmo de
rotterdam y por supuesto nuestro asesor
científico doctor oscar franco
muchísimas gracias por su presencia como
ya es habitual en france24 preguntarle
en primer lugar cuál es la situación
mundial ahora que la variante de alta
amenaza con empeorar la situación de la
pandemia
si esta variante delta nos ha sacado de
base por así decirlo el mundo está
viendo ahora mismo un aumento sostenido
de casos y vimos como en abril y mayo
los casos iban bajando entrábamos en
optimismo pero lo que ha sido junio y
julio debido a la distribución de esta
variante a través de las diferentes
regiones del mundo
hemos visto aumentos sostenidos de casos
que se explican por aumentos en regiones
como en europa como en asia norteamérica
y en áfrica y ahora mismo si miramos los
países con mayores aumentos en las
últimas semanas tenemos países como fiji
como chipre como el reino unido los
países bajos y preocupa muchísimo lo que
está ocurriendo en áfrica que se están
viendo los aumentos que no se habían
visto antes y han servido la vacuna para
contener esta variante delta
esa es una buenas noticias lo que
estamos viendo es cada vez más estudios
con más y más vacunas de las que están
en el mercado que demuestran que si nos
defienden contra la variante contra la
variante de alta contra la infección
quizás muchas personas se van a poder
contagiar debido a la agresividad de
esta variante pero las vacunas parecen
ser muy efectivas en prevenir lo que son
hospitalizaciones y muertes y lo estamos
viendo también no solamente en estudios
sino en datos de la vida real si miramos
a países que están muy afectados por la
variante delta como el reino unido o los
países bajos pero tienen altos niveles
de vacunación el aumento de casos no es
acompañado por aumento de muertes o de
hospitalizaciones contrario lo que está
ocurriendo en rusia o en malasia donde
se ha visto un aumento de casos y un
aumento de muertes también nosotros
hablemos ahora de países o de regiones
concretas no e inglaterra por ejemplo
entró esta semana en una suerte de
liberación de medidas no qué efectos
podría tener esto
esta libertad de medidas o esa
liberación tan tan rápida de
restricciones pues podría llevar varios
problemas en primer lugar esto es un
experimento que se está haciendo que va
a servir de ejemplo para limitar o para
evitar en todo el mundo lo que podría
ocurrir es que en primer lugar por las
vacunas no son infalibles muchas
personas se podrían contagiar algunas
personas podrían morir debido al
coronavirus también vemos que muchas
personas pueden tener el síndrome post
kobe dos síntomas que tú hablan durante
meses y también podríamos tener en una
generación de nuevas variantes debido a
que se deja al virus circular libremente
doctor hablemos de la región de américa
latina que podría ocurrir aquí sea se
encuentra entre nosotros la variante
delta si la variante delta ya se reportó
en varios países y nosotros que no se ha
reportado es posible porque no se ha
reportado porque no se ha detectado en
latinoamérica ahora mismo hay una
estabilización en el aumento de casos y
podría ser que estamos viendo la calma
antes de la tormenta y por eso es este
momento muy importante para acelerar los
programas de vacunación y para convencer
a aquellos que no se quieren vacunar
de que las vacunas los pueden proteger y
que si funcionan contra la variante del
está doctor brevemente para finalizar
nos queda poco menos de un minuto pero
vamos a hablar de la situación en
francia porque en medio de la reapertura
casi total el portavoz del gobierno
aseguró que el país entró en una cuarta
ola de contagios no obstante avanza el
plan de exigir el pase sanitario en
lugares públicos a partir del mes de
agosto esto es suficiente para frenar
los casos que usted podría ayudar
muchísimo no para frenar los casos pero
para frenar las muertes y las
hospitalizaciones macrón se mantiene el
firme y ahora mismo estamos en ese
balance de lo que es la libertad
individual y la libertad colectiva y ese
es el problema de las pandemias que nos
afecta a todos ya veces al que tenemos
tenemos que hacer sacrificios de
elección doctor oscar franco muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
como ya es habitual a nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]